Facebook users no longer have to be either
male or female. And, no, I'm not talking about
Facebook for pets because Mark Zuckerberg's
adorable dog Beast already has his own profile, anyway.
[MUSIC]
Hi, I'm Cristen Conger of Stuff Mom Never
Told You in today for DNews.
Facebook has added more than 50 new gender
designations because guess what? There's a
good chance that not all of its 159 MILLION
American users, who are the first to see these
gender updates, identify as either male or
female.
For instance, according to UCLA's Williams'
Institute, around 0.3% of the U.S. adult population,
or roughly 700,000 people, are transgender.
So in addition to a variety of new trans*
options, including trans* man, trans* woman
and trans* person, Facebook now also offers
intersex, gender fluid, pangender and more.
Now, for those now wondering just how many
genders exist, it's useful to understand the
differences between gender and biological
sex.
Whereas, male/female sex is biologically determined
via chromosomes, hormones and DNA, masculine/feminine
gender is socially constructed, hence the
possibility for the more than 50 categories
Facebook has identified -- which could theoretically
be expanded even further.
The site has also updated its pronoun settings,
allowing people to refer to themselves with
neutral pronouns, rather than just him or
her.
But as always, users can still opt to keep
their gender designation private.
These changes were implemented after the social
media site consulted with a number of LGBTQ
organizations and comes at a time when transgender
recognition is becoming a prominent human
rights issue.
Google+, for instance, also allows its users
to select male, female or other, and a growing
number of countries including Australia, New
Zealand and Germany offer more than just male
or female designations on birth certificates
and citizenship documents.
Although this might seem like an unnecessary
update, speaking to the Associated Press,
transgender Facebook software engineer Brielle
Harrison says "There's going to be a lot of
people for whom this is going to mean nothing,
but for the few it does impact, it means the
world."